now that we have the new 2020 imac some
of you guys have been asking us to
compare it to apple's 16 inch macbook
pro
to see how much more performance you can
get if you choose the desktop route with
the imac
instead of the portable route with the
macbook and since we're still waiting on
the new 10 core imac with the high-end
5700 xt graphics to get delivered next
week
we're gonna compare the current higher
end base model imac
for 2300. with the base 16-inch macbook
pro
for 2400 and then later when we get the
highest
end imac we'll compare that with the
highest and 16 inch macbook pro
with that insane 5600m graphics chip
so if you're not already subscribed do
so right now
and be sure to check out our apple
product merch if this video helps you
out
now the biggest benefit to the imac is
that you can upgrade the ram yourself
so instead of paying apple six hundred
dollars for 32 gigabytes of ram
we simply bought a 120 dollar kit from
amazon
and installed it in just a couple of
minutes and you can watch our ram
install guide if you're not sure how
but on the other hand the 16 inch
macbook pro is actually on sale right
now on amazon
for only twenty one hundred dollars so
it's still a better price
now before we get started with this
comparison i do wanna mention that
there's a small chance
that apple will update the 16 inch
macbook pro with
10 generation cpus sometime this fall
and then there's also the fact that
apple is switching to their own apple
silicon chips very soon
probably sometime next year for the
16-inch macbook pro
but if you need a mac right now this
video is for you
before we get into our performance
testing i want to talk about the overall
user experience differences
obviously with the macbook pro you can
take it with you
so that itself is a massive advantage
over the imac
but we here at max tech use three
desktop macs
for editing so that shows that there's
also some great reasons
to use desktop max one of those reasons
is the extra ports
instead of just getting four thunderbolt
3 ports on the macbook pro
the imac gets 4 usb a ports 2
thunderbolt 3 ports
a high speed uh s2 sd card reader
and an ethernet jack with the option of
paying 100
more for a 10 gigabit ethernet port
along with that the imac
also gets a much larger 27-inch display
with
incredible 5k resolution that's so sharp
that you won't be able to go back to a
4k monitor let alone
a 1080p display but the 3k resolution on
the 16-inch macbook pro
is definitely great for its size and by
the way
this 2020 imac is the first one ever
that supports hdr video playback just
like the macbook pro
which we discovered thanks to an email
sent to us from one of our viewers
thanks carl but what's great about the
macbook pro is that you get the same
great color accuracy
with p3 wide color gamut you get the
same 500 nits of brightness
and true tone technology one difference
that might be huge for you
is the fact that the 2025k imac finally
gets
a 1080p webcam compared to 720p
on the macbook pro so here's a quick
comparison
this is a video and audio quality test
using the 16-inch macbook pro
and its 720p webcam and the studio
microphones
and this is the video and audio quality
of the
5k imac with its new 1080p webcam and
the upgraded microphones
let me know what you think down below
now as far as the speakers
they sound great in both of these macs
much better than a lot of people expect
but the ones in the imac are crazy loud
so let me show you guys how big of a
difference there really is
[Music]
so basically if you're looking for a
desktop setup for working from home
the imac is going to be a great choice
but if you think you might potentially
take it with you
on a business meeting or anything like
that the macbook pro
will be better for you but of course
there's still the performance aspect of
this comparison
and the numbers you're about to see
might finally confirm the choice that
you're leaning towards
and before we begin i want to show you
guys the specs and the prices
while i mentioned that this year's
results will be way different
because the 5k imac now finally comes
with the t2 chip
and amd's latest navi graphics which
both help with hardware encoding
and decoding of hevc footage starting
out with geekbench 5's cpu test
the imac absolutely kills the macbook
pro
in terms of single core performance but
then in multi-core
there is an even bigger difference with
the imac being a
massive 58 faster than the macbook pro
at around the same price and that's
because it's packing
an 8 core processor instead of a 6 core
and then moving on to the cinebench r20
cpu stress test
which factors in the cooling system
performance
the imac is now 81 more powerful than
the macbook pro
which shows that the macbook is
definitely being limited by the thin
cooler design now before we get into the
graphics benchmarks i want to test out
the ssd
speed using the blackmagic disk speed
test
and it looks like the macbook pro
actually has a slightly faster ssd
in both read speed and write speed even
though they're the exact same
size testing the raw graphics
performance of these machines
the imac was a massive 72 percent more
powerful
and the best part is that these new
graphics cards are
finally now built using amd's latest
navi architecture
which will help even more for video
editing as you'll see in just a minute
now moving on to our unigine heaven
gaming benchmark using the extreme
preset
the imac gives you about a 35
improvement
in terms of fps for gaming in general
but keep in mind that both of these macs
have much higher end graphics cards for
gaming
and we'll be comparing them once we get
our higher end imac
in so be sure to subscribe right now and
since that test uses opengl
we decided to run a couple of metal
benchmarks using gfx bench metal 5.0
and in the aztec ruins test the imac was
around 58
faster in terms of fps and for the
manhattan test
there was a smaller difference of around
50 percent more fps for the imac
compared to the base 16-inch macbook pro
i also decided to run
nova bench which uses a mixture of cpu
and gpu to give you an
overall performance score for the entire
system
and the imac was only around 25 faster
in this test
which was pretty interesting now before
we move on to the real world video
editing test using final cut pro 10
i want to quickly run a photo editing
test using lightroom classic
and exporting 542 megapixel raw photos
here the imac was much quicker than the
macbook pro
thanks to that acor cpu and 32 gigs of
ram
compared to only 16 on the base 16 inch
macbook pro
so that's a huge benefit for the imac
since you can get 32 gigs of ram from
amazon using the link below
for only 120 dollars instead of paying
four
hundred dollars for 32 gigs on the
macbook pro
and that's a big deal since ram is
extremely
important for photo editing now getting
into video editing and final cut with
the classic bruce x benchmark
the imac was almost twice as fast as the
macbook pro
thanks to that 5500 xt graphics card and
we saw basically the same results
in our one minute hevc stabilization
test
so the extra time saved can really add
up if you do a lot of stabilization
and then exporting a 5 minute h.264
4k clip which is the most common format
that youtubers use
the imac was faster by about 37 seconds
which isn't as much as before
now what makes this result so
interesting is that last year
the highest end imac with the i9
processor in the top of the line
vega 48 graphics card took even longer
in this test
and that's because the new 2020 imac has
newer hardware technology
so it's very impressive and then moving
on to exporting a 5 minute 4k
hevc clip which is quickly becoming the
new standard format
the imac finished about 27 seconds
faster
than the macbook pro now this is where
it gets insane
and this is what really makes these 2020
imacs
so special the top of the line 2019
5k imac actually took over twice as long
as this new imac
which is over a thousand dollars cheaper
and that's because this new imac
has apple's t2 chip and navi based
graphics
which both help with hardware hevc
encoding
and decoding and for those of you buying
canon's new eos r5 camera
we transcoded 4k 10 bit 422 footage
and the imac saved us about 15 minutes
compared to the macbook pro
which actually was faster than we
expected and to finish things off
we exported a 5 minute canon c200 raw
clip
and the imac saved us three and a half
minutes so it should be quite a bit
better
for high end raw codecs as well so with
all of those tests finished
we can tell you that the imac is
definitely the better choice
compared to the 16-inch macbook pro if
you want as much performance as possible
for around the same 2400 price now this
is actually surprising because last year
we told people to buy the macbook pro
instead
because of the t2 chip and the navi
based graphics
but now the imac finally has both of
those
and by the way it's also much quieter
under load
since it has a larger cooling system and
not only that
but the speakers the webcam the display
and the ports are much better than what
you get with the 16-inch macbook pro
so if you need a high-end imac and you
don't really care that much about
portability
this new 2020 imac is an absolutely
killer
deal in fact we compared it to the 5 000
imac pro and it beat it in many of these
tests
so definitely check out that video after
this one is over but if you want a mac
you can take with you
the base 16-inch macbook pro is still
very impressive
for how thin it is and it's actually a
great deal
since it's currently on sale on amazon
for only
twenty one hundred dollars and if it's
not powerful enough for your needs
we're going to be comparing the high-end
model to the high-end imac
very soon so go ahead and click that
circle above to subscribe
and be sure to check out our apple
product merch down below
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video